my channel is sponsored by athletic
greens which means we will have an ad
from them in a couple of minutes hello
everybody and welcome to i don't know us
talking about obi-wan i guess joining me
today is michael otherwise known as rex
and around we have angry joe and we have
jacob over here from funhouse um and i
think we're all pretty
broad on the spectrum of how we feel
about obi-wan
um and that's part of why i wanted to
talk to you all is like i'm so
interested in hearing these other
perspectives because mine is that i feel
extremely negatively about it i think it
is
almost so bad that it feels objectively
bad and that is like against like my
being like i would never say that i
don't hate it as much as i hated boba
fett but i really don't like it
so i'm gonna go around just in order
michael how did you feel about it what's
your general synopsis of of how you felt
about obi-wan
yeah listen it's it's perfect in that my
best friend is perfect there are flaws
and i accept the floss because i think
it makes it a complete story um could it
always be better absolutely was i a part
of it absolutely so there's that that
you got to kind of kind of go into it
with i was an extra in one of the
episodes so i want to disclose that now
um but no i'm not being paid or am i uh
on the payroll
uh jacob how about you
for me i was a little more in the middle
um
i think for me the strongest parts were
the beginning and the end but i sagged
for me quite a bit in the middle i found
things to enjoy in every episode despite
that
um it was a constant tug of war
between me just like
loving star wars a ton
and not liking what my eyes were ticking
it is interesting my eyes are there
there are things that got me and most of
them are cool lighting most but i was
like good job on the lighting without
that light
that was pretty sick
um joe how did you feel about it overall
what was your general review
the show was just bad
i absolutely hated moments of it and
honestly i'm souring on it as every day
goes by
you know and and to me the nostalgia
berries that are there are just not
enough to declare it uh good
and i think the thing i have the most
problem with is the writing and the
directing it it feels uh
you know at times like an over budgeted
fan fiction film uh
that's the crazy part it looks cheap it
looks so cheap a lot of the time and
sometimes not right it's it's so
inconsistent regularly inconsistent
and honestly i think it damages the lore
i think it damages cannon um and what
ways do you think it damages cannon
because my approach that night oh
i don't think we have time for a top ten
time so i feel it
it doesn't like necessarily specifically
damage cannon i think what it does is
nerf cannon or
um so like one of the things that i have
an issue with is spoilers obviously if
you're watching here i hope that you
knew that there would be spoilers
it is time to talk about ag-1 from
athletic greens ag-1 by athletic greens
is much more than just a greens powder
it is a nutritional drink that i love
using and have been using for absolutely
years since well before this sponsorship
you're watching right now you will have
seen me drink it on streams that i
really love because it makes sure that i
get so many of the nutrients that it's
really easy to miss with a fast-paced
lifestyle it has 75 different
ingredients including adaptogens
probiotics superfoods vitamins minerals
it's just jam-packed full of health
benefits and outside of being able to
put it together really quickly and just
down all of the nutrients that i know my
body needs to get me through the day the
thing i found the most rewarding for me
personally with ag1 are the energy
benefits if you're busy and on the go
you often need energy and i'm a person
who has very little energy anyway but
aeg1 has a natural form of b12 never
synthetic biotin bioavailable folate and
magnesium that really really helps perk
you up especially if you have it in the
morning such a good way to start the day
of course there are plenty more things
that can help you with like performance
and recovery if you want to recover
quicker from workouts ag-1 is packed
with superfoods and adaptogens including
magnesium which helps with muscle
recovery it tastes nice and fresh and
all it actually requires is one scoop or
travel packet of ag one eight ounces of
water every day that's it so it is very
very easy to drink it's really
refreshing has a ton of benefits there's
essentially no downside so go to
athleticgreens.com
to get started on your order athletic
greens is going to give my community a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
that is athleticgreens.com
alana pierce qui-gon gets stabbed to the
lightsaber and we're like well that's
that done uh but then rava gets stabbed
twice and she gets stabbed twice because
an inquisitor is stabbed she says that
she's alive um
how did anakin not
sense that she was there
why did obi-wan not kill darth vader why
did obi wan not kill darth vader like
stuff like that i realized that makes
him responsible for so much all of the
atrocities that come afterwards yes so i
wanted to ask the two very big star wars
fans on the other side
i imagine that you like you know you
have like how you reckon with some of
this stuff but but how how did it get to
a point where like it didn't matter to
you
like hey
i like that she's talking to us like we
are absolutely out of our minds for
enjoying it it's really hard
to listen you guys are you are out of
your mind
it has a saving grace and that flea is
now canon in star wars
great chase scene no i'm not asking how
you're how you like it because that i
can totally understand that's a lot of
like expectation what you go in
expecting like and i don't think there's
any fault in that what i'm asking is
like how do you feel about the ways that
canon has been shifted as i'm using it
nerfed like as as
as it affects this like even the basic
stuff of like you know later clearly not
being sad when obi-wan dies in the
future
yeah about filling in like
how do you feel about that that kind of
stuff
um like for for me
it's
always interesting because this is
something that i think star wars has had
to deal with with
having prequel stuff in general like
there's like a throwaway line and
revenge of the sith
that um
anakin and grievous meet for the first
time so they can't meet ever in
six seasons of clone wars or whatever
yeah which is uh hilarious um so now
we've got like okay how do we have
a whole adventure with obi-wan and
princess leia and make it like seem like
it's not weird
um
in episode four and i think i
was okay with a lot of that like i was
willing to
like
um
put up with that closer connection
that didn't really exist before and um
stuff like uh darth vader and obi wan
fighting again
um
when the show was first announced like i
was personally like i don't need darth
vader in the show at all really
like i'll take uh just like one
adventure tayden christensen teases is
what got me excited
yeah yeah and then
without darth vader in this series it it
wouldn't even be worth watching
yeah i turned around on that with this
show for sure so i guess it's something
that like
you you can just let go like is that
that kind of the resolution is that
you're like i'm just you're just okay
with it you just kind of like don't put
a lot of stock in it yeah exactly
because like at the end of revenge of
the sith was basically just connecting
those dots immediately without anything
in between i'm like that's way dumber
than this happening in this show for me
personally um so that's just me
yeah and and and to second that i look
at star wars as a as kind of a growing
and evolving organism and i think i look
at it that way because of what we've
been given over the past five ten years
um
if it was time locked and secured and
boxed up and put away on the shelf um as
is lord of the rings or you know the
harry potter
series
it's it's untouchable and it is what it
is and you can add around it but you
can't change what it is but star wars
since george lucas has always changed he
kept going back to his movies adding new
cgi new scenes new characters new
musical numbers and so for me
however you want to say it's bad it's
definitely subjective but you are you
are right in that it it changes the
essence of what the original story was
and i think to be a star wars fan or to
be a happy star wars fan these days um
it's good to to acknowledge like that
this thing is going to continue changing
under us and for me i've always said hey
if i don't like it let me work to
actually be a part of changing it and
and that means you know anybody who's
upset with it
i always say like dude i just i
literally just showed up in kenobi i was
a star wars fan and i was able to show
up in kenobi you can literally do
whatever you want if you want to ride a
star wars i say go ride a star wars and
go add to it and go change it and so
that's kind of how i feel about it it's
this this very creative piece that
morphs and and evolves and so for me i'm
along for the ride until i'm until i'm
driving the actual vehicle
that's interesting you're incredibly
lucky to get that opportunity i mean
that is true it's not a standard i i
definitely definitely stole some rocks
from set don't tell me nice
i i think that the the canon stuff like
aside from
like obi-wan not killing vader is like
the single thing that made me go oh
what the rest of it i was just like [ __ ]
it whatever like it's like it's fine for
a while until it's not i think the
biggest criticism that i actually had at
the show were writing issues um i think
that there's like
a potentially very interesting story
with what raver does being an inquisitor
who you know i mean it was clear from
the first shot of the show that she was
a little girl there was no way that that
opening shot wasn't gonna be her anyway
the whole thing was very predictable in
that sense but
you know infiltrating to try to kill
vader is a potentially very interesting
story but i felt like what they ended up
doing with her character was
so jarring in that almost every episode
she had a different motive yeah i
definitely agree that execution was a
big issue yeah a lot of the time and i
found that like almost scene to scene
sometimes they seem like they would
intentionally write a scene to have a
little plot twist in it almost every
single scene character changes someone
would say
we have no time and then they'd be like
no wait we can make this work
like two would be a very next scene so
so so
yeah that was the stuff that i found
very hard to like overcome with the show
and i think that that could just be that
i'm a writer it could just be that like
that's how i look at things that's the
things i'm trying to look at things from
as far as it actually damaging canon and
whether that matters or not i'll give
you some more i'll give you some more
examples but that's not even the big
thing the big thing is just poor writing
in general that's all writing for the
motivations uh making vader just a
buffoon uh you know
rebel could have been an amazing
character i'm like one of those people
that always wanted to see a dark side
female sith badass i mean uh
george lucas had this idea for one in
the series that
yes talon so i've always wanted this and
and then when i see it executed it looks
i mean honestly reva or riva however you
say your name is
riva it's great on paper but on
execution was poor and we'll talk about
why but let me get back to what i was
saying so let me just say as far as
damaging cannon you guys gave some
examples here's some more bail organa is
so stupid and not only that but he is a
war criminal now oh it's a traitor to
the empire and the grand inquisitor is
still alive reva told him this so he
knows the link between obi-wan and
and uh
and and leia
and
he they know bell organa is
collaborating with traitors at this
point and they know that leia has a
close relationship with a jedi uh
and so it's like
like you said the list of things that
that break canon is not small
no michael go ahead can i add to this so
i think what what we're overlooking is
is that
hubris has always been a part of star
wars uh and that's the overconfidence
and and so i i looked it up to give you
guys the exact definition excessive
pride or self-confidence and that was
originated from greek mythology george
has always added hubris to his
characters this overconfidence that
allows vader to leave his enemies alive
that allows obi-wan to leave his enemies
alive it allowed obi-wan to leave him
alive in episode three it would have
been very easy to sink a lightsaber into
his head uh kind of like the geonosis
battle arena but he didn't do it and so
to me this doesn't break canon because
star wars has always had these
characters that will
walk away
after a victory and we're talking clone
wars so we're talking the mortis trilogy
uh there's a there's a dozen different
references that we can pull from where
they should have finished off their
victim the grand inquisitor to kanan uh
the grand inquisitor to ezra vader to
ezra and yet they don't do it and i
think that's a big part of star wars
storytelling
like
mole no foreign
not coming back like that part's fine
but choosing not right he didn't
he he killed him very quickly but then
doesn't kill vader even though vader's
just been like by the way anakin for
sure dead dude for sure dead anakin's
super dead he's
and obviously it's about is your
suspension of disbelief broken at any
point
and the problem with obi-wan is my
suspension of disbelief got broken but
you know what i'm a huge star wars fan
so i'll allow it i'll allow it in
episode one two three when we get to
four things are fall for me i was okay
with one and two one right after one
thing right after the yeah me too i was
like eight out of ten i was like let's
go yeah i think four years away for more
but eventually you get punched so many
times that you're completely out of the
story and you're starting to notice all
of the scenes you're starting to see
actors writing and saying terrible
dialogue that makes no sense you're
seeing these characters that are usually
smart act dumb in order to advance the
plot like the fake jedi guy uh you know
dropping the communicator for noah i
actually
you're right that it is about kind of
our own capacity to suspend disbelief
and be along for the ride and i think
that's a very big part of it so like
when i talk about the thing i like the
least it is the writing um to ask the
two of you who are more positive how did
you feel about the writing generally how
do you feel about uh riva like did you
have any any um
maybe high points like things that you
think were written particularly well
yeah jacob go forward i have a two-hour
lecture to draw
yeah for me like i'm kind of in this uh
similar book to joe with riva
cause like i was really excited to see
her as a character and i like like the
performance and stuff um but like with
this show being so short and focusing so
much on obi-wan i feel like her
motivations were kind of always a little
clouded for me like i didn't even really
know what was going on in the last
episode
what was her motivation there
jacob i'm like what is called justice
yes
revenge would have made more sense but
even then it almost seemed like she had
a redemption art wreck before that i
actually didn't like her performance but
i should have gone to directing not
young
adventure
and it's like uh
with the obi-wan and stuff i think
it was i guess i just would have wanted
to see more like introspection and stuff
i mean i always i enjoy ewan mcgregor's
performance he kind of carried me
through the whole thing
like a six episode series i feel like
yeah it was a suspension of disbelief
thing because i go back to episode four
where they're infiltrating the
the inquisitor's fortress oh my so many
things where i'm like it's like she left
like so tala's there she's dressed as an
imperial officer she's sneaking in i do
like that um yes
uh
what's what's her the actor's name
indira of arms right yeah yeah she was
super good i'm like oh you're so good
dang it then they [ __ ] leave with the
trench coats jacob yeah the trench coats
and then like she landed
on the on the counter top and opie woods
like on the other side the commonly like
hello it's a reference to a new hope
okay they're giving us crumbs here look
it looks exactly like the thing in the
new hope but i'm like there was was
there wasn't there a guy like sitting
right there yeah that's the problem okay
in a new hope there was nobody right
next to me okay yeah here's here's okay
did any of you watch episodes one
through three and i'm not talking the
show i'm talking the prequels because
you're all picking this thing apart but
we were just sitting here like 15 years
ago saying yikes this writing wasn't
everything that it could the writing is
bad
now good point good point now we make
rlm's videos on it
so there's so much nostalgia and there's
so much that we love about it and that
to me is star wars because i honestly
can't argue that i will give the
prequels so much right ways like i can't
i'm not even done at this point listen i
think what marvel is doing story wise is
so much more full and rich
in terms of
episodic chapters of a larger story but
i don't think star wars was ever that i
think star wars is space adventures and
wizards and lasers and lightsabers and
that to me is these these it is missing
things and i'm happy to talk about what
it's missing but i will say that there's
so many elements of this that riva to me
was a direct parallel to anakin but
flipped whiny over the top aggressive
emotions unchecked
angry but it was this kind of flip to
where i think now riva is set up we have
her character development for better or
for worse in the series a lot of time
was given to her i know a lot of people
wanted to see more kenobi invader but i
think now she's set up to be a really
big player in the galaxy because now we
have the backstory and now we're ready
to go and we have this dark side user
that's very
balanced that gave up the dark side oh
joe i am so ready for you to hear your
rebuttal
but i do think this is very star wars
and and i'm saying i listen
it's not perfect like i said it's not
perfect i can pick it apart too i think
we all can't but i just i think it's the
mentality we go into it with is like
give me a good space adventure with some
anakin some ob1 and some continued and
expanded lore that's that's what i'm
excited about i'm a little relieved she
didn't uh kick the bucket at the end
because like that seems to happen with a
lot of characters that change their
minds no no give me joe hit it hit me
freaking it's always called obi-wan
show the whole time
you know the writers injected this
character why why did we knew it into a
new character we had so many inquisitors
already in the lore why couldn't they
use the uncle fester gran and qui he
looks awful by the way i'm just doesn't
matter they made the grand inquisitor
look so crappy same thing with the fifth
brother he's supposed to be massive tall
and as imposing as darth vader and now
he's i don't know this knockoff bicycle
helmet memes are very funny so they
created a revit character to mimic darth
vader to mimic kylo why did we need it
now get now here's the thing i like
ingram moses or mogus is ingram
i think she is a great actress and [ __ ]
anybody that is you know talking [ __ ] to
her for you know racist reasons or
sexist reasons because it is not her
fault the writing in the show she does
as best as she can and in later episodes
she's doing her best to make it work the
problem is the character writing for
reba is atrocious
i don't think that she was handled
the a role that is very well on paper
it's solid but in execution it la here's
the thing i mean going from her her
motivation for at the start is
kill jedi to then suddenly it's about
get information from leia that leia
never would have had anyway for some
reason and then at the end it was about
get closer to vader and the stupid
decision of like why didn't we leave
obi-wan outside the front to wait for
vader to come to distract him it's like
so much
i don't think that's bad i think her
directing is bad i'm so mad the way they
handled reba because the whole show i
think everybody agrees the whole show
lacks tension okay and how could you
have got tension through reva without
showing reva's kind of intentions or
conflict at the beginning she is so over
the top she is so annoying go back and
watch the episode even the inquisitors
are like god shut up you know it makes
the entire audience hate her we need a
scene or two of her alone where she is
she's not yelling conflicting she's not
yelling she's
she's hiding things from the inquisitor
raise that tension you know uh in maybe
episode one or two she could have been
great but the problem is it's she's so
unlikable it's difficult to care for her
and
and honestly
she should have died she can't that
makes her character so much more tragic
she goes against vader she's going to
attack vader but there's no possible way
that she can win against vader she will
die against vader and and letting her
live it takes away from that entire
character because i saw that with trilla
we already saw that story with trilla so
why retell that story and so to me
everything joe everything
everything you just said you could have
replaced that with hayden christensen or
anakin and put it in 2002 or 2003 and it
would have been an article about hayden
christensen in the prequels and that's
where i'm like i'm trying to like try to
try to set expectations of star wars
fans to be like it's been this way for
20 years i'm not saying that's in this
level i'm just cutting them talking
about did you know much attack
it's not perfect dude i agree with you
it could be so much stronger and i think
she deserved more and i think the show
was rushed these episodes should have
been an hour plus
no no
absolutely
show her conflicted resolution she
literally walks by pickled younglings
every morning when she goes to work
and all of a sudden she can't kill
younglings are you serious
no
i keep trying to mention this sorry just
quickly
i do think that deborah is a great
director but i did feel like her moses
ingram's direction was really appalling
and that like it just very much seems
like an actress who's being told to be
angry 100 of the time and yell 100 of
the time so we don't really get like the
one time that she felt a little bit more
human was when she was talking to
obi-wan and then it was like oh okay you
give me a bit more of this and i want to
board it but when you just have somebody
don't just your time just uh
you mentioned uh i'm sorry go ahead no
no you got it yeah joe you mentioned
tension and i think like it would have
been really important for them to nail
that with riva because
she it's her in a show surrounded by
people that are still alive in the next
movie yeah exactly so you know what
happens to them it's like we know
everybody is going to make it through
this
um yeah and
more it's more so intact um so it's like
we got luke not know about lightsabers
he was climbing up that ladder real fast
don't you do that jacob i'm just kidding
like his head
even if he had forgotten
because he bumped his head
the people of tatooine clearly they were
like these guys adhered to
jane over there got a hand cut off by a
lightsaber and luke just didn't hear
about any of that he was going there joe
i i gotta i gotta address something are
you killing jedi and hanging them in the
court square okay go ahead go ahead i
gotta address something with you i was
watching an episode uh you did recently
because uh i do my research and uh i i
noticed you
you were kind of upset with how gangster
brew and owen were and i would like to
give you a little bit of lore that's
going to add to the gangster of who baru
and owen were in the comic books they
were a part of the underground railroad
to free slaves on tatooine and they
killed a lot of people they were like
jesus oh your average dream doesn't go
through 17. that's why i'm here
to tell you that's why it needs to be
shown in the show
it needs to be shown to show everything
this stupidest thing happens two farmers
are going to take on brandon underground
his wife
we don't need help we just need me and
you you're gonna get killed
[Laughter]
i don't even set up fire they're they're
both in front of her watch re-watch the
scene they're saying their techniques
were sound directions well it's they're
on tatooine that's tattooing that is the
direction of deborah chao i don't think
she knows how to frame action she's
constantly doing shaking i was not a fan
of shaky
cinematic series is so weird
cinematography
where there's a hundred storm troopers
barreling in and nobody can hit anything
i mean i i know i shot i shot a few
people but it got cut i know they're bad
shirts okay it got cut well there was
also the
when they're at the base
and the two speeders come in
and they're like heading towards the
door and then they just gone in the next
shot they should have either
crash-landed or like very quickly pulled
out but they just disappear um there's a
lot of it looks so bad alana it looks
those speed you remember the moment
where she's standing there blocking the
shots from the speeder it looks like
loading there somebody was holding toys
or or the one coming in from the side 78
star wars yeah
it was like uh i think that episode when
it hit that point
that was kind of like my lowest moment
with in the show um oh that episode i
thought was very bad oh i got a text
from rahul coley says if you [ __ ]
praise obi-wan i'm gonna come over and
smash your gundams i'm listening
hey do not [ __ ] threaten that man's
gundams
thank you joe michael i wanna tell him
where he can put him on what you were
talking about there so like i i think
that i'm generally in agreement that
anyone who hasn't watched the extra
media shouldn't have to watch the extra
media to understand who the characters
are but the conversation that you're
having there is still something that i
find interesting so there are
yeah they were part of uh they there's a
quite a long storyline where they're
part of the kind of underground railroad
within tattooing to free slaves and they
get very violent and i think that's uh
obviously you're right i do agree like
show and somebody in the comments said
show don't tell i don't know why i'm
reading the comments it's very
performant um but they said show don't
tell and it's a great point and i
totally agree but at a certain point are
we just gonna have the most basic
vanilla star wars because the lore is so
expansive what's another universe
outside of marvel that has lord this
expansive when i watch marvel movies i
have to go hammer to a youtuber
yeah i got to go to a youtube video
after though and say the top 50 things
you missed in doctor strange and i'm
like whoa that was really enlightening
and i'm glad i watched it but that's
kind of where we're at in these fandoms
if we want these stories to keep being
told and listen i'm not trying to to
to give an excuse for every mistake that
was in this series because there's
plenty of mistakes and there's plenty of
mistakes in the original trilogy there's
plenty of mistakes in the prequels being
a star wars fan means being okay with
having some weird and kind of bad
writing at times and i'm not trying to
justify that joe i'm not trying to
justify it i do think you have a great
point and i don't i just don't want star
wars to continue with the bad writing
this way
i think we're starting this now we're
gonna get more of this derivative drivel
and poorly written things
all they needed to hire was one mega fan
they just hired you
they should have left me in the writing
room
behind the camera
the shot in here because it explains
this thing
and and i don't disagree but i also want
to add to this and
and just being a part of this it it's
funny because i lose so much credibility
i actually stopped doing my youtube
videos on my podcast when when i got put
in it because not only do i really
respect the ndas but i also yeah exactly
like i'm done i've lost all credibility
to them and that's fine and i've got my
community it's cool but what i will say
is holy crap i've never been a part of
something because of kovid that was so
strapped and in my opinion put it on
hiatus let's get through this pandemic
and i don't want to talk too much about
behind the scenes because it's it's a
big thing but i will say
i
witnessed it and there is absolutely
a piece of that that strongly affected
what we saw and that was no that was on
no part of the the crew that was working
there the directors the writers they
were dealing with a really bad hand but
i would show up and half of them would
be gone
and it was like that was the mentality
we were going through and it was like a
fight for survival to get this thing
done and so i think i have a lot more i
think i have a lot more empathy i have a
lot more empathy
and
that were really really really good
though so it's like did they have disney
but did they have the disney rules
behind them no do you know how much
money disney has no no no but the but
the safety the no no no the safety rules
like the safety and precautionary
systems and structures put into it i'm
again i'm saying i'm strict i'm
admitting that that we have we
definitely have some missteps but i do
think that's multi-parted and you can't
just
throw it up to like that there's context
to it so michael we currently have you
on the defense it's very easy to be
passionately angry which i also am i'm
having a good time i want to give you
the opportunity to say like what do you
think is the number one most
number one thing the show does most
successfully what is the thing that you
think it does absolutely the best the
thing that that makes you really love
like what what is that for you to me it
forgave obi-wan
and that's i think
if nothing else we got that we got
obi-wan saying
it's not my fault we get obi-wan in a
position where he is a new hope alec
guinness to where he says vader betrayed
and murdered your father and he can say
it because in the past i was like well
from a certain point of view but now we
got hayden christensen as anakin saying
you didn't kill anakin i did and to me
that was really important because i'm
such a fanatical obi-wan kenobi fan i
mean the obi-wan merch i have in my
house is ridiculous and so
it gave
the justification to somebody who was so
broken and so hurt and so like in pieces
because i couldn't relate episode three
obi-wan to alec guinness as obi-wan i
couldn't relate it i didn't see it and i
never did and i honestly never saw
anakin to vader and this show bridged
that gap and if nothing else i'm really
grateful that it did that i only see
anic innovator because of clone wars
that's the only way that worked for me
it was like a patch um and i think that
like i don't disagree with that i just
wish it had been done in a way that was
like much more about obi-wan
psychologically like maybe he didn't
need to go abandon his life's work which
was making sure luke was okay on
tatooine and we could have seen you know
him go through that journey in a
different way i think there's something
very interested and interesting about
like the tortured slightly distant
father figure who's trying to deal with
the fact that he like doesn't know how
he feels about the force now and he
might have to deal with this kid like i
think that could have been done in a way
that didn't mess with all of this cannon
and the the biggest criticism i have of
disney star wars is just it just keeps
making the universe feel so [ __ ]
small and there's so much eu stuff that
was really cool that that's now not
there anymore i don't disagree one bit i
don't disagree one bit i think that like
it redeems obi-wan but then immediately
damns him again by walking away from
vader it's it's very tough yeah what
would you have rather seen joe
probably i would have so you did
australia
that's not my name i think that i would
have like maybe like you know i would
have written a completely different show
but if it were to get to that final
scene and they're like you need to write
this i would have had a reason that
obi-wan couldn't kill him i would have
at least had something that was like
some push away you could have the empire
show up yeah
star destroyer keep disappearing from
orbit where are the tar fighters i guess
don't get me started alana what launch
all fighters i just realized
[ __ ] vader walks up and says
increase firepower it's like i heard
that i heard that from you for seven
hours
like beginning the attack and then two
little ships
the visual was funny of stormtroopers
the whole [ __ ] star destroyer has to
chase one ship and caught a ran out of
fighters every single fighter pilot was
in the [ __ ] they had diarrhea
and it was the same diarrhea that they
had at the grand inquisitor's [ __ ]
base when the thai fighters magically
disappeared in episode four and they're
sitting there with their thumbs up their
asses as they watch the speeders fly off
into the man in the trench coat with
and leia all fit in those air speeders
those things are so [ __ ] small they
can fit one deck in the back but they
can't fit all three of those
jacob what did you feel most positively
about like what was your most positive
takeaway from the show it was it was
stuff in that last episode like we
talked about like bridging anakin and
darth vader and stuff i think this show
was the first time that i like i mean we
saw the anakin or hayden's face inside
the darth vader helmet but this is the
first time i was like oh i can see these
characters i finally see these
characters as the same person and like
they did the cool stuff with the voice
modulation doesn't that also happen in
rebels it was really interesting it does
slightly but not as not as because that
they cut the other side of his mask so
it's a soaker that cuts yeah it's ahsoka
yeah yeah it's a very very star killer
does it in the video games that's true
if vader keeps getting beat up by all
these
apprentices should get a new mask yeah
yeah i want to talk though about no joke
i have to ask you first
without any if butts or or whatever
what's your most positive takeaway from
the show
what are you what's the most positive
one in the show what is the thing you
like about it the most uh neck breath
and
uh obi-wan uh hayden christensen
returning to the role you and mcgregor
returning so all of their moments the
quiet moments are [ __ ] fantastic that
training scene that training montage was
awesome
um i actually don't have a problem
everybody complains about the first
lightsaber battle i do think that uh you
know kenobi needs to be pretty weak uh
you know in that initial battle he's not
trying they're not gonna whip out their
revenge of the sith fast lightsabers no
i don't expect that nobody expects that
so i think uh when it focuses on i don't
know obi-wan the name of this show
that's when it's good i don't understand
why we had to have a leia escort mission
throughout the entire episode sure um
episode or two but like they make uh
they make luke the dumbest little kid
and leia is the most amazing character
who's so good at everything she can even
hack [ __ ] blast doors and then she
forgets how to hack a blast door in
return of the jedi so much so that i
think she gets shot in the arm when han
solo's trying to hack the blast door she
doesn't say anything the problem is they
ruin the leia arc when she's already a
badass at nine years old like she can do
no wrong and i don't like saying this
because
people who i hate and despise use these
same words but mary sue we don't need to
build up leia to in a ridiculous over
over-the-top you know point characters
are more interesting if they have flaws
and it makes luke an idiot like look
sucks ultimately joe i agree with you on
that note but i will say you see how
bumbling skywalker wasn't a new hope
took control luke skywalker was bumbling
dude he was a bumbling an animal i hope
leia isn't and leia's and leia is like
into the into the dumpster shoot fly boy
like dude there there is that essence
now you know what you're right it was
over the top at 10 years old sure there
was definitely some cinematic
for sure i don't disagree with you and
i'm not trying to say that she was
really cute though but i will also say
she was out in everybody like that
that actor is is a sassy to the core but
her performance was really good
considering it was it was it was good
and i'm glad that she's not getting
bullied the way that jake lloyd was
because yeah there i mean the writing
the writing's not it's not perfect
you're 100 right i'm not trying to argue
that but i will say it was very
reflective of a new hope luke and a new
hope leia but the dial was turned up to
ten and it was and it was a lot and i'll
i agree with you on that yeah so i
actually didn't feel that they made luke
an idiot just because i feel like i
didn't even see we just wanted toys yeah
does have the privilege of just being a
kid on tatooine like yeah okay
absolutely i didn't feel like they made
them dumb they definitely made leia
unbelievable again it's it's yeah i
think you that this is right and that i
hadn't thought about and i appreciate
the perspective of so much of this comes
down to how much you're willing to
suspend belief uh potentially there are
still probably star wars fans who like
doesn't require that at all it's perfect
that i would family disagree with i'm
just glad she didn't like get all her
toys like in solo like oliver like when
she got taller's holster i'm like well
she probably like left that in alderaan
when he got blown up yeah where's lola
too jacob oh no dead gone dead he was
also an alder on properly there for
merchandise and now dead no the lord the
lola bot yes very cute tala died in the
lola bot you know
i mean we never see it again i guess if
they do a season two i mean despite all
this you know me hating it i kind of do
want to see
an obi-wan qui-gon jinn like bloody
training series but they could have just
had that this time yeah exactly
what about like what if they started to
do one hour specials that's what i've
been saying is like don't give us these
whole limited series just give me a one
hour special give me a window into their
life for an hour and show me what's
going on and then let's move on because
that's that's where i'm at personally
yeah i think like with qui-gon like
while we mentioned qui-gon like i do
wish as happy as i was seeing liam
neeson just because i can't help myself
um
i do wish that like his involvement was
more like pivotal to obi-wan's like
arc and his growth and stuff
and it's because we know where everyone
came from and exactly where they're
going to we know where they're going to
i think is the bigger problem we know
who they are the next time that we see
them and that means that the arcs just
kind of have to go around in a circle um
like i really would have liked to have
seen a more tortured obi-wan something
like a little bit more hesitant like
maybe you really drag out
leading up to the moment where he
actually turns a lightsaber on but that
it happened a lot faster than i would
have thought like i feel like i wanted
to see him tortured and see that
perspective a lot more than i alana you
the blame lies i know again it sounds
like conspiracy theory stuff the blame
lies with kathleen kennedy and i
actually like kathleen kennedy but you
can look up interviews uh why like some
of the decisions that he makes to let
dave and john
think
otherwise i hate kathleen kennedy
because there was no plan for the disney
sequel trilogy and i will never forgive
her so i take back my statement i hate
it but here's how she [ __ ] up obi-wan
too look it up it's in an interview she
said the original scripts for obi-wan
were too dark right they were too dark
she had them rewritten so the one the
series that you wanted alana is the
series that kathleen said nope uh we
gotta we gotta turn on that lightsaber a
lot quicker i sort of know somebody
who's a producer on the show who i don't
probably give
essentially said the same thing like it
was very different and i'd talk to you
guys you know off the record as well
about that same thing because things
changed very quickly um but i will also
say joe you mentioned like they have to
build lay up but did you not get enough
luke in mandalorian season two or book
of boba fett i mean they're building up
luke too oh damn i love that they're
building up the hell is it in the middle
of boba fett season two
telling people don't watch boba fett but
at the same time i have to tell them no
you have to watch boba fett episode
whatever yeah
brilliant they're building up luke as
well i think they're building both up
and luke's gotten so much time in the
sun
uh the sons that he's gotten to kind of
now take a back seat as we explore more
of leia i i like leia i think obviously
it's like i said it's not perfect but i
did enjoy understanding alderaan more
and understanding her reference to i
barely remember my mother and she
describes the things that obi-wan said
to her about her mother and i'm like
okay we're starting to bridge gaps here
because in a new hope which if you want
to poke holes in this thing how does she
remember her mother so i'm taking it
back to the very first movie in 1977
nothing has ever held together perfectly
and that's it but i disagree is that
return to the jefferson she remembered
what yeah
about her mother and father then she
would have mentioned that right in that
moment she doesn't well it hadn't been
written
i have a happy feeling so you pointed
out something that fixes when it
actually no she didn't say that uh uh i
can and i can look up okay
i can look at that oh [ __ ] we seven
receipts now boys let's [ __ ] go she
said that her mother was beautiful but
sad in return jedi but that was what i
was like how do you remember that with
like the 17 words he used yours just
like your mother you're
strong made me happy
it made me feel
he's a creepy piece of [ __ ] she says to
him you make me feel uncomfortable
making me uncomfortable
no come on padme it's never been made
that's why the situation with men online
is so toxic these days is because they
all learn from anakin
so let's
she said she doesn't want me i'm going
to tweet her 15 more times
by the end um so then michael you keep
mentioning it's not perfect it's not
perfect but you've not actually given us
a flaw so what's one thing that you
don't like about it yeah speed man like
let us live in these moments and and and
let us like understand them better i
feel like they were like look okay look
okay and and that's what i felt like
this whole thing um
my wife and i as we watched it was like
wait why why why is this happening so
fast why is this already happening it
was this sort of like sprint through
this series and with a 12 episode series
i would feel better about that but we
had six it was limited and they're like
it's that meme where it's like okay hang
on hang on wait okay let's run let's go
let's run and it's just and we were just
being dragged along this whole way and i
feel like they didn't give these
characters like riva a chance to
be to earn that appreciation by the
fandom to earn that respect and earn
that admiration they were instead saying
here's a character we've made admire her
now here's a speed run of her character
arc i will absolutely agree that that
that suffered and i don't 100 understand
the creative decision behind that
because i think the show if it could
have breathed a little bit more or even
had been broken into hour-long episodes
or 10 episodes it would have changed so
much of like that character development
that everybody here is complaining about
you know i i also you know i want to
advocate because you're right because
it's in the middle either extend it with
12 episodes and give us that context
with rev at the beginning that we're
missing that builds the tension or in my
opinion make it a film i feel like this
is a film if you just watch i agree last
two episodes five and six you're good
you don't need all the rest of the stuff
if it was a film you would have got the
riva stuff tight and hell maybe riva
wouldn't even be in that version it
would be focusing on obi-wan and those
those moments with obi-wan and anakin
and things like that so i think it would
have been more effective as a film but
look it's the streaming wars right
disney needs content they need watch
hours and they need this thing to happen
so either they give us the 12 episodes
like you want or they give us this half
thing which is what they gave us i think
the writing kind of suffered a little
bit like that's what i was thinking
about this um
because like it's just six episodes like
he said michael and
instead of having
leia get kidnapped twice
and like having a rescue thing happen in
the middle of that just like find a way
to get rid of the whole infiltration of
the
the fortress thing
it's like
those windows are very fragile it's also
the
the entire scene with riva and leia
where she is interrogating her didn't do
anything other than justify kind of
why she was going to be such a piece of
[ __ ] to leia so obi-wan had more of a
reason to rescue her that scene doesn't
serve
raver at all nor does it necessarily
serve leia nor does it add up with what
riva's plan is that's why i would have
like
rather had something else done with all
the time spent in that episode is
because it doesn't really advance
anything except having a tracker on lola
yeah
and
i think like
the the tracker thing
and vader getting mad at riva about it
it's a problem i have with
with with any story where it's all part
of the plan
um
like they've been every mistake that's
been happening has been controlled by
this villain like uh it's a thing that i
had a kind of a problem with with thrawn
and rebels because he's like this master
tactician so it's a kid's show so he
loses constantly but he's just like it's
all part of my plan
oh they do him justice i think i hope
he's gonna be in ahsoka that would be
that would be cool that'd be badass but
like live-action thrawn yeah i just i do
think they just kind of wasted time with
some of those episodes that didn't push
things forward and that would have been
time better spent uh like building
something else up yeah i don't disagree
and joe you mentioned earlier like i
kind of like faulting kathleen kennedy
for for this and
i i i kind of feel a little differently
because i before she kind of was was the
new owner of the star wars car uh she
was a producer on some of the most
incredible movies some of the most
important movies to my childhood
and and i do think yeah that it's it's
i respect that very very much and and
tell me if you think i'm wrong on this
because i think
yes and she gave it to favreau and
filoni well that's the only reason why
it's good is because she gave it okay
but then check this out i do think that
there is a
a a sort of a link that we're not seeing
as fans that is the money machine that's
the disney corporation and that is
lucasfilm and i think a lot of the times
we put a lot of this uh responsibility
on the creatives at lucasfilm or the
producers at lucasfilm or even the
presidents of lucasfilm when it's this
like
dicta dictatorship style production
cycles that these shows have to do to
keep relevancy and to keep money up and
we're like kathleen kennedy sucks
kathleen but it's like
i think she's giving the reigns to the
right people but this machine is causing
this sort of like cloud that's covering
all of these creatives well now forcing
them to work out the disney sequel
trilogy irreparably like i cannot say
she and i think it was a disney monday
machine i would i would quicker blame
iger than kathleen kennedy on that and i
don't know all this way i don't watch
that you're a given steward of the star
wars universe and you don't have you're
right you're right there's account
joe you're right there is accountability
there absolutely when you have overlords
that are telling you you're out if this
doesn't work you speed to get these
results i think exclusively blaming
kathleen kennedy is too convenient
the mega corporations there are so many
[ __ ] people at work that it's like
yes i also agree the sequel trilogy is
like oh my god what happened to holy
[ __ ] yikes that last movie oh no i will
never watch it again
is but she has um approval in fact she
met was messing around she said colin
trevor i don't like you i don't want us
you're i don't like your script i don't
like your direction even though the
whole initiative initially for was hers
i want three different directors i want
three different visions but she didn't
like it she didn't change colin
traverall's vision i think deadlines
changed i think finance has changed i
think money needed to change and i think
that's what happened i i i see it as a
much bigger thing and i do think you're
right she is accountable absolutely
you don't take on the sequel trilogy
without having it planned out that's the
thing that i have the problem with they
were making it up as they go especially
for how much money i don't disagree
it's absolutely nuts that it turned out
the way that it did but i don't disagree
yeah a separate conversation and i think
that a lot of people somehow palpatine
has returned oh god and i generally just
don't love disney productions
in general uh
a little bit about like the
responsibility accountability and stuff
it's like i like debra chow's
mandalorian episodes oh yeah like they
were some of my favorite ones and that
made me have high hopes for this show
bryce dallas showed him i was high on
his favorite mandalorian episode and
then my most favorite pope fed episode
yeah and then i like the other bryce
dallas howard did another mandalorian
episode that i liked a lot
i hope they give her more but i thought
her first one was dog [ __ ] like i think
that a lot of it really does come down
to the scripts like it's so hard to say
we're we're being armchair right now
michael's the closest and even then it's
like really it's so hard to say how this
stuff actually falls apart in the way
that it does it's so much bigger in
terms of production than we can even
[ __ ] fathom but like in my head i'm
like these scripts are just well look at
the right possible each episode every
single episode has a different writer
why that's pretty normal on tv
yeah joe come on maybe it needs to
change maybe no
listen and and without exposing the same
tv this is streaming i'm trying to be
very cautious but i was there for six
weeks for one episode we shot 30 takes
we shot 30 takes on every scene
um so there's so there there's there's
something there and i don't want to talk
too much about it i won't talk too much
about it but i was on set for six weeks
and that's a long time for one episode
and so there is something more to the
story that we aren't getting as fans
and you know until they're like michael
why don't you take a platform and talk
about it i'm not going to say anything
but there is something else going okay
do you guys think that's that's then
then maybe this thing is as best as it
was going to get it's possible do you
guys think that there is a um still a
conflict for star wars in terms of
trying to balance the people who've been
fans for 30 plus years and kids like do
you feel like that's still a war that
they're facing right now and that could
have impacted obi-wan because i don't
know if this show is made for children
it almost doesn't feel like it was to me
i i don't believe in making content
stupid for children children don't like
stupid content they they like the con
go ahead somebody else did yeah it's i
don't think like make something being
dumb is an excuse for it
um in the end because like there are so
many
things that like you could consider like
kids movies or kid friendly stuff like
like lion king or any like don bluth
movie it's like these things scare the
[ __ ] out of you a little bit when you're
a kid but it's the stuff that sticks
with you it's like you're definitely
making steve
yeah it's like very good exactly it's
like
there has to be some kind of
emotional payoff and like sometimes a
little bit of trauma in these things
because that's the stuff that really
makes you think when you're a kid so
like i think with star wars like it can
be approachable for kids
but also be like value like a valuable
experience for adults too like it's the
stuff that hits everybody well it's
clone wars the same it's that is it
connects to both and i i will say i have
a i think i have a younger audience than
in all of you just because i'm very
heavily clone wars and so i had a bunch
of 14 year olds and uh so you know it's
it's everybody's talking about kind of
this this this sucking objectively but
it's not objective it's very subjective
and i and and listen i had people at my
office at work like
people who had never watched star wars
because they knew i was going to be in
episode 5 were watching the series
people who were very distant to it and
they were coming in and i'm talking
action sports people not nerds like us
and they were like wow i loved how they
did this and it was so cool how they did
this and they had criticisms but i will
say
it was very like widely accepted outside
of just this core fandom and i think
man i'd love to see somebody who's
talking about it we look at this as if
our nerd core is all of the fandom but
we don't see this like broad kind of
like casual viewers and and as a
corporation they cater to that as well
so i do think like subjectively a lot of
people thought it was an incredible show
and i think i'm able to look at it
through their eyes and and really like
love and admire all the parts of it even
the flaws like i said because i have
flaws and they make me special and we
all have flaws i'm not trying to get all
yeah nickelodeon on you guys but it is
dude i respect this
appreciate our beating is weird on you
bro no but i it's so so you all guys
need to look up lego star wars the free
maker adventures i love it i watched it
i love it disney plus series and it is
[ __ ] good isn't it really it's good
i've never watched you can find it on
disney plus now they didn't have it on
there for a long time they just put it
on this one free makers free maker
adventures they remixed the star wars
they do a lot of things it is so smartly
written it is so funny and it is for
kids that show's writing is better than
obi-wan's writing and that says
something subjectively it is yeah i'm
going to have to actually check this out
i know what you're talking about i love
clone walls
i'm in agreement that like
for kids you should still write things
with intelligence kids are going to find
fart jokes and people falling over funny
they're going to find lightsabers cool
they're going to find big spectacles
cool um you don't need to dumb
characters down for children to
understand them they'll just grow to
appreciate them over time but i still
think that there can be like for a mega
corporation a challenge of like how dark
can this be how realistic can we be with
his ptsd like yeah from an ethical
standpoint i don't know but i i just was
like maybe that's part of like what
happened with his production because i
it's very difficult for me to even
fathom
how the writing turned out the way that
yeah what did you like about it
i thought the lights were pretty i
thought they did some pretty light stuff
a lot yeah very briefly like that was
kind of an interesting thing watching
this movie they often had good lighting
yeah
see it even mcgregor like on sets and
things and having a lightsaber that
casts light on his face i'm like i
haven't seen this before yeah and the
shift between red and blue was good
gregor hit it out of the park the the
shift between red and blue in the final
fight was very cool but also it just
made me go okay so he just moved this
over here for that to happen and i
couldn't get that out of my head i have
like he just had to sort of
swap it over for some reason so it would
be red but i i like i thought that there
were a lot of things that looked pretty
i thought there were some things that
looked really budget i think ewan
mcgregor is a fantastic actor and like i
always wanted to watch him and the way
that they got me like the thing that got
me excited for the show and and i knew
it like when he did the [ __ ] reaction
video to that trailer i was like being
pricked uh was like jewel of the fates
and you give me the breathing can you
give me all this [ __ ] that i'm like come
on
and then it just like didn't give me the
saturday thank you for bringing that
what do you think alana about the music
in this series
i think
um i think it's very hard to compose
star wars because you're competing with
john williams and trying not to copy his
dna and that's going to be a real
challenge i also found it very
forgettable yeah yeah
it's not good guys it is not memorable i
would say absolutely i don't really
uninspired stale
can i give you i think it was three out
of ten joe
i agree with you joe
it was missing that wait star wars music
is oxygen it fills up the screen it
fills up the space and it kind of adds
so much goes hand in hand bro we lost
that character i agree joe i'm with you
on that one man
on youtube have you seen guys you all
need to look it up they're on youtube
right now somebody remixes uh you know
using the badass star wars music that
disney has in their [ __ ] vault yeah
and they mixed it into the the last
fight there and it was so much better
than the generic [ __ ] it was it was just
very absent like yeah it is a character
that it was missing the only the only
theme i remember from it is just like
the part that john williams wrote like
that obi-wan theme there you repeat the
repeats over and over and i'd also say
the the i i did read uh today deborah
chow had an interview where she said she
purposely held the imperial march for a
time that vader deserved it and i like
that i liked when it showed up and i
just and i just said that i didn't like
the rest of the music but the fact that
they decided to hold that till the time
that vader deserved to have that
imperial march i think that added so
much and again we're sitting here six
episodes being like where is it yeah but
it's just sort of creeping a little bit
it is this is it's this problem that
happens with like weekly episodes rather
than a movie release or an entire binge
kind of drop at one time is you have to
wait for it and you're like well where
is it and so for six weeks you're angry
because you're like wondering where this
important part of the story is but it's
like it's coming and it is there and it
is part of it and i think it's tough in
this like streaming age to be like now
wait every single week like you did back
in the tv days because we've been so
used to binging and getting the whole
story in one go so i do think that is
discrediting the project like i think
when you ask me the stuff that i like my
problem is that all of the stuff that i
like is stuff that was put there
specifically for me to like it's all
member berry stuff like i did like hello
there yeah and i go oh he said the thing
and i'm like this is the thing
it's been driving me a little bit nuts
and i like i try not to do this because
like for anyone who enjoys the show i'm
happy that you like it no part of me
wants you to not like it i don't have
that in me like it that's awesome of
course but watching people on twitter
put like a shot from obi-wan and then a
shot from a previous film and be like
look they're the same
well yeah it's the same guy it should be
the same this shouldn't be celebrated
like it's genius that the same character
did a similar thing and i keep being
like why are you praising that so much
and then i'm like it's okay they're like
having fun and that [ __ ] got me too the
mummification of
like the hello there thing i love it
like it's so much of the prequel stuff
it's like it ruins so many just normal
phrases that's like him saying hello to
a boy it's like sure that's a thing he
does he says it to r2 we didn't freak
out about it like i anytime like i use
high ground every so often to describe
things
and it's like i have to like tell people
like i'm not so what in the chat said
they're called parallels alana you're a
writer come on yes they're not
impressive that is so they're so bad
now that we're going to have 20 star
wars tv series we're allowed to be like
hey this particular one not that great
this other one fantastic you know what i
mean we need to praise the ones that
have great writing like mandalorian and
we need to let them know when the
writing and the music and the
choreography and the characters are not
written to a level that fans expect from
star wars i mean look at this i've got a
list pulled up in front of me let's
count them together
uh so obi-wan is already out i'm not
going to count that so you got andor tv
series you got tales of the jedi
animated tv series you got bad batch
season two you got mandalorian season
three you got young jedi new adventures
you have star wars visions volume two
you've got ahsoka tv series you've got
the recently announced star wars
skeleton crew with jude law you've got
the acolyte tv series
season two yeah there's a bad match
season two you've got the lando tv
series that's being talked about that's
ten you got the taiko with td star wars
movie yeah did you get rogue squadrons
rogue squadron
you got the book of boba fett season two
possibly oh god
you got the kevin feige star wars movie
maybe he can come in and rescue it
you've got and then you've got all this
canceled one star wars rangers of the
new republic ryan johnson star wars
trilogy and david benoff and dby star
wars movies oh man i forgot about that
yeah hey joe when did they have when did
star wars have good writing in your
opinion i i just want to know like what
so let's talk episodes oh you're saying
that but then i have no excuse for that
to continue the bad writing george lucas
was not a screenwriter
it's sand i hate sand it's course and
and no it's because i'm so in love with
you you know hold on if anybody said
that
you would crack up laughter i would have
been i would have had that guy jailed
and it's fair to say that that's what
some fans love look at me i'm surrounded
it is there is a sort of fun corny like
okay
style star wars
your embracing new hope is my comfort
movie i've watched that movie ten
thousand times and it is so
into the into the trash you fly boy like
it's just there's so many very corny
that's good corny bad corny is then your
opinion i mean that's where it's like it
is and somebody was like there's no such
thing as subjective in writing well
there is because there's shows i hate
and there's shows i love and there's
episodes of star wars i really don't
like look i'll i'll say it mandalorian
had
i or boba fett had i had such high hopes
and i really am just i don't i
personally don't think robert rodriguez
is super well cut out for the star wars
universe i just don't i feel like
there's not enough reverence yeah and i
like him and other stuff i love him but
there's not this like reverence that i
think needs to be had and that's where
i'm like i'm kind of hoping for a season
two because at the end of boba fett
season one he goes i don't think we're
cut out for this yeah and in my head
that sets me up of like oh okay so they
realized
that's what i'm saying
they they set him up to be that to be
like oh okay i'm not set out to be a
government governor i'm going to go back
into what i was and i really like that
and i'm looking forward to that but i
will say like yeah it is it's it's hit
and miss and and star wars for me the
cornball writing doesn't turn me off and
it doesn't turn off a lot of fans okay
and i'm not saying that it's right or
wrong i'm just saying the writing to be
overly cornball in ob1 i found it to be
like a confusing jumbled mess in which
like i said earlier characters in the
same scene contradict themselves from
two sentences beforehand like yeah like
there's a
ice cube's son does yeah i was gonna say
like he's like we can't like you brought
a jedi here we can't like have him here
well he's putting us all in danger okay
i'll help you please help us yeah it
wasn't the corniness it was the
inconsistencies with characters that um
i almost feel like they wrote it without
having like character bios or character
sheets they instead wrote it with a plot
and were like and then this needs to
happen and then this needs to happen and
that just like makes it very hard to
relate to any of the characters or
really care about any of them the truth
is i didn't care i didn't really care
about anyone i care about leia i care
about obi-wan a lot of course i do but
that that like came with the show from
the start so
for me it wasn't that i felt like the
writing was cheesy or corny
it was that i felt like it was almost
written as those scenes were written by
different people and then put together
like they were barely even connected new
writers it's a really bizarre way i like
when boba fett says
i'm tired of the [ __ ] fruity it's
gonna get us all killed and then he
parks slave one face down in the sarlacc
and shines a flashlight
he came out of it in
yeah
i was like dude what are you doing
all right when were you guys out on the
series at what point because you
obviously went in hope okay we like one
and two
okay
where were you so it was once i showed
up got it perfect
it was a [ __ ] blue hat i swear to god
yeah no it was the same and then i think
like i
unintentionally soured myself a little
bit more by then like when i went back
and watched and i was like wow they
really stopped to inquisitors because
this jedi just knocked down some cloth
and then like i just my perspective got
worse and worse and worse and i am at a
point where like i appreciate where
you're still at joe
my point and a lot of people on the
internet i'm gonna like this is i'm
never watching any disney star wars ever
again this is my i don't know
not for me oh i'm out i can't do it
anymore i think it's really bad can one
of them bring you back you could bring
me back on the like flip side so now i
am never going to watch any of it ever
again i'm like i don't like it
i would if the reviews are really good
so like you're gonna wait
yes so it's like i'm not gonna opt in
now i'm not gonna buy the marketing
you're not gonna get invested to be
disappointed exactly i will still watch
it if it like ends up being good and
people that i trust say it's good and i
have a parometer from people like you
guys i'm just otherwise i am like that's
it i'm out i'm not [ __ ] doing this
anymore i wouldn't lie i need to watch
good tv why do i keep watching [ __ ]
garbage star wars and it's it sucks to
be at that point because it's still like
especially when it's something that you
love and you're attached to i just when
i realized that all the stuff that made
me go oh cool was wild but pretty
lightsabers or
just like nostalgia beats i feel you i
mean i'm a star trek fan and do not
watch the car do not watch
season two oh my god
opinions on
yeah yeah the first two episodes like i
it's a bummer that
still i still like leia like i was drawn
out of her obviously being excessively
mature but i still liked that and i was
like into that i was like continuity
questions that i am willing to
completely dismiss like i'm cool i'm
along for this ride and then i felt like
things just really fell apart like i
didn't think episode
for me like it was i was one two three i
enjoyed up until the part with all the
fire where he was rubbing obi-wan oh my
god yeah and then like yeah that's the
moment i guess we have to just i think
that that fight even was the moment
where i felt like it looked very cheap
but i guess with that we have to
accept that he didn't want to take him
like obviously vader could have he
didn't want to and and the logic is
because he wanted him to suffer well why
wouldn't you capture him and have him
suffer privately
yeah it's like he wanted to do it
himself maybe but why not do it himself
anyway yeah and then like it was like
taking him alive the draw like a very
slow droid and just
oh he could have killed him like we have
to infer that he didn't for some reason
but the show never answers yeah he gives
up way too easy because can i glance at
his prey i want to hear it go ahead okay
so okay
all right uh there's the moment when
they're both in the back to tanks
and it's flashing between the two of
them
and what is invader's memory it's vader
in the fire scene but if you watch it
it's reversed and he's lifting kenobi
out and away from it and then you see
vader struggle you see anakin struggle
go watch it joe it happened he lifts his
hand up out of the fire rather than
putting him down and then in the final
battle
we see
hayden christensen anakin oh he
through the fire in the episode but in
the back to tank flashbacks he lifts him
out of the fire he lifts his hand up
it's in reverse joe okay i watched it a
lot of times okay so
and i think this was just missed and
again show don't tell i'm not saying
like you guys are idiots for missing it
like it should have been more clear but
how does that okay i'm with you
that's when you got to show vader being
a bully no knocking him down constantly
so he can get up so that vader can knock
him down but no and i'm not i'm not
disagreeing but i am saying that i think
the reason why he let him go was because
there's still conflict in him which is
what luke said to him a dozen times
there's still conflict in you i know
that there's good in you and in the
final scene when the helmet gets sliced
open for two or three different shots he
doesn't have the red eye and there's a
tear coming down his cheek again too
dark for anybody to see i over analyzed
everything i looked at every frame i saw
it and it there was a tear coming down
his cheek there is still good in anakin
and that's why in my opinion he let him
go and they didn't
i'm not saying you're wrong for being
like what happened i'm saying it wasn't
clear enough that it showed the entire
series that vader is still fighting with
anakin inside the suit and it's not
until the suit is broken open and
anakin's exposed that he becomes more
machine than man now and i think that
just wasn't okay it was amazing yeah
you're right if the director had brought
those elements a little forward and made
it more clear but they just brightened
the exposure a little bit very dark that
[ __ ] was so muddy i liked the idea of
that projector i was like what is it
what's going on and i think that's a lot
of the problem with it is like there are
so many things in this and and maybe
that's what makes it like more
frustrating is when you see a lot of
things that are good ideas like riva
that then aren't executed upon it makes
it more disappointing when you're like
oh but you had a bit of it and then it
it kind of came into my mind we were
talking about um the imperial march
being saved for like that last moment
and stuff is like that whole last
episode felt like there is i mean other
than some of the riva stuff it's felt
like there's so much intent
like behind this one whereas like some
of the other episodes felt like it was
just kind of floundering through it and
this was like okay they have something
they want to do with obi-wan invader and
they're executing on it and it's it's
working for me at least so like i was
like i wish that could have been in
a few of the other episodes or you know
it should be in every episode there
should be intent behind everything and i
think we're done with shaky kim i think
we all need to agree that shaky cam
somebody mentioned it in the chat
earlier it it it's just it doesn't feel
reverent like star wars cinematography
that's not star wars
it's kind of rogue one in that in the
trenches you can get a little bit gritty
with it but yeah when you have these and
more stuff yeah absolutely
totally agree
i want to say
i appreciate you coming out to explain
things
swinging over here i i i appreciate it
though that's why i want to talk to you
it wasn't it wasn't like to put you on
the spot is to get the perspective it's
like i for sure think that that stuff
should have just been in the show
um yeah and and it also like is still
your interpretation i've seen like way
different interpretations so it doesn't
even seem like that's like
solidification subjective totally yeah i
said it so it's right
you know what else should have been in
this show dexter [ __ ] jester are you
right i would have saved this whole
thing for kidster kitster could have
easily made it
drove up and if that car with the mole
guy with zach braff in it drove up and
he was like
won
i'm gonna be like all right i'll stop
right here i haven't seen you since i
was prospecting i'm thrilled i'm glad
that not too much of it took place on
tatooine i'm sick of the dog you got
away from the sand there you go there's
a positive front yeah well hang on we
got a red dirt instead
that was good
um i'm trying to think of the things
that i really liked it doesn't matter
though like again i want to like leave
this by saying
i if you like it i want you to like it i
don't want anyone to not like it i
couldn't stand it
i feel like i was just like and i was
just like so frustrated so frequently
like like just sitting on my couch going
what all the time and i don't feel like
i should be watching tv that that has
that uh influence on me
but what do you think about i know
you're not going to watch it anymore
until you get some good reviews in are
you excited about the next one and or no
i'm done
no done because that's part of it is
like the people who [ __ ] about like
fandoms that they don't like or ips they
don't like but continue to consume them
why like just watch all the [ __ ] dude
like i don't want to be that person
either if
people that i love people like all of
you like and or then i'll watch it but
i'm not in i'm not doing it like ahsoka
was the one that had me the most excited
as i personally really likes clone wars
but even then i'm like
not [ __ ] doing it i'm watching andor
that's okay
yeah i feel like andor has
expectations
gonna
no
like the trailer i was surprised by
because i didn't really care at all
yeah oh really it wasn't shot on the
volume
that's gonna be your first one not shot
on the volume it's gonna feel gritty
it's gonna feel real and hopefully they
go the soldier angle the wars angle and
star wars that i can call up a line and
be like hey this [ __ ] is good that's it
you send me a dm when it's good yeah
only after the whole season i don't want
any
of me being like the first episode was
good it's gotta be the whole season
don't do that tomorrow jacob i'm so
excited for episode one uh the fog
clears the rebels start to approach and
who is leading them riva
i immediately turn it off no i would
really i would really like her to to be
good is the thing i just and um
i'm sure she won't it's like she's alive
might as well do something potential for
it i'm still pissed that she got stabbed
twice and we just [ __ ] left quite
gone to die it was it was the same hole
that was the problem
you know
often fixes itself afterwards so if they
do do a riva series as not as much as i
might hate it they might be able to fix
her character by showing the moments
that she's alone
in this in this series that we never got
to see the moments that she's alone
conflicted and as flashbacks and then
also show her in the future so you might
be able to still fix reba it's the clone
wars anakin treatment yeah yeah and it's
like with ahsoka like i didn't like
ahsoka when she was first introduced
right she was really annoying for a long
time
but you would have to have a beloved
yeah way better writers and way better
direct you'd have to give it to dave and
john and they would they would maybe be
able to fix reba but other than that i
don't know a cowboy hat's full of ideas
listen if there's anybody viewing that
needs a
refugee to a safe space if you still
like star wars you can come find me it's
a very safe space there joe won't get
you positive you're like
oh jesus
i was going to ask you earlier michael
if owen and beru do they kill watto in
that
uh i i no no i i they don't as far as i
know
they yeah they could but uh yeah there
you should check out the comic series
there's a there's there's a name that
they go under and i'm blanking but uh
you just type in oh and beru comic
series it'll come up but it actually
just so you know it adds to episode four
where they're burned alive you're like
oh my gosh they went over the top and
it's like no they probably put up a
fight before they were finally killed by
the empire it really does retcon a lot
in a really good way okay yeah so just
wars um so does anyone have any any
final
things they want to show any lasting
impressions anything they didn't get out
um
okay at best dexter jetstar would have
saved the show
we can all agree with that joe
uh just
all all of the really ridiculous moments
stand out in my brain right now and i
would love to forget about them you know
the uh leia parkour reva park you know
just all of the silly moments and i just
i i i'm like you alone i wish probably i
didn't see episode one through four and
then maybe just came in for five and six
together
oh no i mean yeah i'm even disappointed
by five and six but it's like there are
little morses here and there that i
liked from obi-wan and maybe it was the
pandemic and and there was some behind
the scenes stuff like rex and said and
and i understand how hard it is and
and how much pressure there is to live
up to a star wars series and i respect
you so much for coming out rex and and
defending it and and being positive on
it because honestly if they put me in
star wars they make me a sith i will
[ __ ]
i will [ __ ] defense to our world
well you make me a sith in the next
movie um i appreciate that it's still
expanding that [ __ ]
like you're still like like part of the
passion comes from still being a fan and
wanting things yeah i'm a huge huge fan
as long as nobody's out there yelling at
people when they do like it that's the
only thing that i well then yeah and
this kind of proves that four people
with very different opinions are able to
in a really humorous and fun way
co-exist together and talk about star
wars i mean i i thought i got to say i
think i was more nervous for this stream
than i was before my episode came out
and i had like serious anxiety but i was
like oh i'm gonna get i'm gonna get
wrecked i don't know what to do thank
you for coming on i appreciate it
and and i really appreciate you guys for
having fun with it and and and to me
star wars is
it's i collect stuff obviously i make
stuff i collect and not all of it is as
good as the other stuff but to me i'm
like i cherish every single moment and i
wish people could as well but i
understand i totally understand why they
don't and i understand why people don't
like it but for me personally and the
reason why i kind of keep it to myself
is because i just love every little bit
that i can get my hands on because i
have this hyper fixation uh with star
wars this this attachment to it that i
cannot break and so for me i'm like let
me figure out how to find joy in every
little element even when it's even when
it's the book of boba fett and it's
disputed by gangs i'm like let me laugh
with it let me let me let me joke about
it let me make memes let me think it's
funny because there's no point in me
being angry about it because i have no
control now someday i think i would like
to have a little bit of control over it
and i think i could do something really
cool with it but until then i'm just
collecting pieces for my collection and
they're not all great they're not all
front stage pieces i respect that that's
like how you've chosen to enjoy it like
that's totally 100 fair and i like i
again i wanted to talk to you because i
was like i need to understand this
perspective like what and i get it like
i totally got what you're saying
and that's that's part of it like we do
that with different ips everybody has
ips that they pick and choose which
things are okay you have successfully
called me out because i've completely
forgiven the prequels for all the [ __ ]
that i know is wrong with them but i'm
not forgiving the new stuff like then
that's talking 20 years yeah i was
talking about criticals
yeah they need to get away from this
original stuff from this old stuff they
couldn't agree more
knights of the old republic or far
future stuff and just start new because
the star wars universe is way more
expansive than than like you said
earlier lana that it's getting too small
it's way too small it's so nuts you
could do so much cool stuff like high
republic is right there they're fleshing
it out so much do something with that i
mean acolyte that's supposed to be like
a high republic show so i don't like i
don't know about the high republic but
if you can go old republic um
go even older yeah and old republic all
right cause you get that braveheart
stuff where you know you did you you
know those cgi videos they made for the
mmo god i wish i could they're good
uh jacob where can people find you they
can find me on funhouse the youtube
channel making some goofy stuff over
there and then i also stream twitch.tv
slash jacob full j-c-o-b-f-u-l every
monday i build gundams so a lot of
condoms you got back there
yep a whole lot of running out of space
joe where can people find you
the angry joe show
angry joe show on youtube and angry joe
show on
twitch what else are you reviewing right
now
uh right now i'm playing through
starship troopers i [ __ ] love
starship troopers that movie so long ago
it's just a nostalgia trip so i'm going
through that one right now and that'll
probably be next cool uh rex in a round
how about you you can find me everywhere
at wrexham underscore around i've kind
of pulled back since since uh you know
being in it and uh but i'm pretty active
on twitter so come hang with me there
and i'm currently really enjoying the
show orville i don't know if anybody
else is out of it is is enjoying it but
if you can get past uh seth macfarlane's
bd little eyes it's really good it's a
really good series that's a deal breaker
for me no can't do it
i had to get the orville plug
thank you
to the three of you for joining me i
appreciate the chat thanks everyone
watching live on twitch the youtube will
be up tomorrow but it seems like the
twitch chat has mostly been pretty
agreeable too i appreciate you all
whether you loved it or hated it i
respect your right to do that making it
sound like it's constitutional but it's
true
i respect your opinion i'll see you guys
next time